un bonsoir à tous mardi 11 décembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv et
soixante dix huit l'actualité locale en
26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition un mardi noir dans les lycées le
syndicat une aile appelé à une journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme du
baccalauréat de parcours sur plusieurs
établissements ont été bloqués dans les
yvelines certaine mobilisation dégénéré
avec des heurts entre jeunes et forces
de l'ordre qui ont procédé à quatorze
interpellations ce mardi ils ne sont pas
satisfaits des annonces du président de
la république fait il hier les gilets
jaunes de coignières continuent leur
mouvement devant le dépôt des carburants
est depuis quatre jours ils sont
mobilisés sur place pour effectuer des
barrages filtrants et ne compte pas à
décanter enfin les salariés du plateau
de satory à versailles vont pouvoir
bénéficier des services de navettes
autonomes elles ont été inaugurées hier
ses véhicules innovants développés par
vider comme roule à 15 km heure et
circulent grâce à une antenne gps relié
à 16 satellites
une première en france et puis nous
dresserons un premier bilan du téléthon
sur le secteur est divine avec son
cordinateur daniel base en est la colère
lycéenne s'est encore exprimé
aujourd'hui le syndicat une l appelaient
à une journée noire un mardi noir une
journée de mobilisation contre parcours
sup le service national universel et la
réforme du baccalauréat
plusieurs blocages dans les
établissements à signaler dans les
yvelines et plusieurs débordements sur
ces images à poissy au lycée charles de
gaulle où l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre a été nécessaire les policiers
ont essuyé des jets de projectiles une
bouteille d'acide a été également lancée
à versailles des lycéens de jules ferry
ont manifesté dans les rues et ont
allumé un feu de rue royal 14
interpellations ont été effectuées ce
matin dans les yvelines à poissy au
lycée descartes de montigny le
bretonneux et à la plaine de neauphle
attrape le lycée de la plaine de nos
fous le blocus d'hyères a réuni une
centaine de jeunes et ce blocus a
dégénéré un grand feu de poubelle a été
allumé devant les grilles de
l'établissement ce matin les stigmates
de la veille sont encore visibles une
nouvelle mobilisation s'est déroulée sur
place réunissant moins de personnes
lycéenne a accepté de témoigner à visage
caché elle dénonce certaines villes
ce policière c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude et de nickel et le
nid d'euros malgré tout ce qui s'est
passé
les policiers n'avaient pas droit de
tirer dessus au flashball je tiens à
préciser qu'ils ont vraiment tiré malgré
tout ce qu'ils peuvent dire ils ont tiré
ils ont visé des gens moi il ya un lit
et un policier qui m'a lancé une infime
hygiène dessus et il a fait exprès il
m'a regardé y avait personne autour de
moi il m'a lancé un fumigène déçu on
était encore un petit peu parce que
étant donné les événements oui c'est
normal mais non on nous tirent dessus
ils nous lancent des fumigènes on nous
parle mal et avec mon placo julien lecat
mon soir en soir vous êtes le secrétaire
régional du syndicat alliance police
nationale des yvelines une réaction sur
ce qu'on vient d'entendre cette lycéenne
de trappes dénonce des violences
policières sur ce mouvement des lycéens
qu'avez vous à répondre on voit dans son
intervention en qu'elle dit qu'elle
s'estime déjà un peu coupable donc il
faut savoir que moi mais mes collègues
face à des violences urbaines parce
qu'on peut qualifier ça de violences
urbaines quand mes collègues font face à
des jets de pierres des jets de
cocktails molotov ou parfois des jets de
bouteilles d'acide
évidemment que mes collègues réplique
avec l' usage de moyens lacrymogènes
voilà quatorze interpellations
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines de
nombreux heurts entre les lycéens et les
forces de l'ordre avec parfois des faits
violents vous avez parlé de ce jet de
bouteille d'acide
il ya même deux policiers municipaux qui
ont été blessés hier à sartrouville le
climat actuel il est très tendue dans
l'île est très tendue effectivement ça
fait un peu plus d'une semaine que les
forces de police sont mobilisées
tous les jours sur des rassemblements
lycéens casseurs parce que nous on
assimile plutôt certains groupes à des
casseurs il faut bien faire la part des
choses entre les lycéens qui ont
certaines revendications et des
individus qui viennent et qui profitent
de ces rassemblements pour venir casser
brûler des véhicules et attaqué les
forces de l'ordre est ce que ces
effectifs de police pour faire face à
ces nombreux blocages sont suffisants
alors ils font ils font face avec
beaucoup de courage il faut savoir
qu'ils font avec les moyens qu'on leur
donne je prends un exemple de notre
combat compagnie d'intervention et de
sécurisation du département lui et cie
qui est composée que d'une cinquantaine
de fonctionnaires quand il était
quasiment 150 il ya une quinzaine
d'années donc il faut savoir que
malheureusement sur le département il ya
une baisse des effectifs de police de
manière globale tous les services sont
touchés
et c'est là que nous notre syndicat le
syndicat alliance s'inquiète beaucoup
mais je tenais et je profitais
d'ailleurs ce passage en bateau pour
féliciter mes collègues qui font un
travail remarquable depuis quasiment
huit joueurs sur le département
alors dans ce mouvement des lycéens il
ya eu forcément cette polémique à
mantes-la-jolie une vidéo qui a choqué
on voit au niveau à l'interpellation de
150 jeunes quasiment en marge d'une
action devant lycée jean rostand
on y voit les lycéens agenouillés et les
mains derrière la tête alors des
milliers de lycéens en france qui ont
manifesté aujourd'hui on reproduit la
scène en solidarité
alors camarades vous vous comprenez que
cette scène est plus choquée cette vidéo
ait pu choquer non en fait si vous
voulez face à on voit que déjà il n'y a
pas eu de blessé parmi les lycéens aucun
blessé parmi les forces de l'ordre
l'interpellation comme on le voit se
déroulent dans le calme
donc effectivement face on va dire à 7
ce nombre exceptionnel d'interpeller
vous prenez des dispositions on va dire
inhabituelle a effectivement façade à
des individus qui étaient armés quelques
instants avant il faut le savoir qu'ils
sont attaqués aux forces de l'ordre et
il était nécessaire d'avoir en visu et
les mains d un des individus est
effectivement d'éviter la fuite donc mes
collègues ont estimé que cette position
point groupe de 150 personnes était la
meilleure c'est la réaction tout à fait
proportionnée vu les circonstances vu
le contexte exactement il faut savoir
que ça faisait trois jours que mes
collègues subissait de véritables
attaques de bandes armées
il faut savoir que ces individus étaient
pour certains armés
donc pour s'assurer de la de que ses
collègues que c'est que ces interpellés
n'était plus dangereux il fallait avoir
en visu les mains alors vous venez
interpr vous n'avez vous n'intervenez
pas face à un groupe de 150 comme vous
intervenez face et un groupe de trois là
entre autres c'était la meilleure des
choses à faire dans les policiers qui
font face à une colère aussi plus
globale paquet a pas que celle des
délices est en ce moment dans le pays
avec ce mouvement aussi des gilet jaune
on a vu des images d'affrontements à
paris également dans toute la france
l'état du moral des forces de l'ordre il
faut savoir que ça va faire maintenant
plus de trois ans que les forces de
l'ordre sont mobilisées depuis
malheureusement les adh mandat de
janvier 2015
on a eu des périodes successives d'état
d'urgence qui en fait a restreint mes
collègues au niveau des congés il faut
savoir que la superposition des missions
fatigue mes collègues et en fait ce qui
est surprenant c'est que vous avez d'un
côté une augmentation des actes
terroristes et des actes de violence
urbaine et d'un autre côté vous avez une
baisse des effectifs et des moyens
alloués pour le maintien de l'ordre
oui on en vient à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure il ya clairement un
manque de moyens exactement ou en
voiture sur le département
on a des problèmes de véhicules qui sont
inadaptés pour l'émission quand je vois
les brigades anti criminalité du
département qui ont des véhicules qui ne
sont pas adaptés pour recevoir le poids
de leurs équipements dont vous avez des
véhicules qui sont inadaptées un manque
de véhicules pour les services
d'investigation
parce que derrière en fait derrière les
150 interpellé que vous avez un mantes
la jolie
vous avez 150 procédure qui suivent et
il ya un travail qui est fait par mes
collègues procédurier qui a été
remarquable d'ailleurs et qui eux
également manque de moyens une dernière
question votre syndicat au niveau
national avait appelé début décembre à
l'instauration de l'état d'urgence pour
répondre au climat de violences
actuelles c'est un état d'urgence qui a
été appelé notamment pour répondre à la
menace terroriste mise en place d'un
couvre-feu renforts de l'armée
est ce que c'est encore nécessaire
aujourd'hui alors rien il ya trois côtés
positifs sur quand vous êtes en état
d'urgence vous avez la restriction des
deux périmètres de sécurité vous avez
des perquisitions administratives et
vous avez les assignations à résidence
donc là ce qui permet de neutraliser
d'éventuels casseurs et des acides et
astreintes de rester chez eux
il faut savoir que nous on demande une
assistance de l'armée mons à ses plus
hauts niveaux de paris et de notre
département pour justement prendre ce
qu'on appelle chez nous les gardes
statiques pour justement recentrer les
policiers au coeur de l'eau m 2 de leur
métier un mois mes collègues qui font du
maintien de l'ordre et qui sont
astreints à garder des domiciles de
personnes politiques
cette mission peut être fait par des
personnels armés de l'armée et voilà ce
qui permettrait de gagner en effectifs
et en opérationnalité merci julien le
cam d'avoir été avec tiens vous vous
êtes le secrétaire régional du syndicat
alliance police nationale dans les
yvelines sur ce sujet des gilet jaune
dont on parlait d'ailleurs quatrième
jour de mobilisation avec un barrage
filtrant devant le dépôt des carburants
à coignières ils se sont organisés pour
poursuivre leurs manifestations
quotidiennes et après les annonces du
président de la république ces
événements en attendent plus de la part
du gouvernement le reportage sur place
de nicolas landry un village de gilet
jaune à l'entrée de la zone industrielle
démarré à coignières des citoyens avec
des situations sociales différentes tous
mobilisés contre la politique du
gouvernement
nous on commence à prendre racine
il ya une chose qui a apporté ce
mouvement et
et indirectement le président c'est une
solidarité
il a réussi à voile a rassemblé quand
même pas mal de demandes et on commence
à se créer une petite famille de gilet
jaune et de ceux qui soutiennent à
travers un barrage filtrant les gie les
jeunes s'organisent pour faire vivre
leur mobilisation ce matin des élus de
coignières sont venus leur rendre visite
après l'installation d'une benne à
ordures par les services municipaux pour
voir quelles sont les quels sont les
besoins fait faire en sorte avant tout
que ça se passe bien aussi bien pour eux
que pour les automobilistes qui passent
s'il ya une volonté de donner la parole
aux français aux citoyens par
l'intermédiaire des mairies on le fera
enfin ça me paraît une évidence
augmentation de 100 euros du smic prime
d'activité comprise défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou suppression de
la hausse de la csg pour les retraites
inférieures à 2000 euros
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron est jugée insuffisante
beaucoup de personnes ici que je veux
que j'ai rencontrés m'ont bien fait
comprendre que voilà c'est ça suffit pas
ça suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir d'achat voilà c'est juste vivre
j'ai entendu c'est un premier pas qui
est intéressant maintenant il ya
tellement tellement tellement tellement
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés qu'au final en fait c'est du
vent je le prends comme ça sert que
quand on quand on est sur une
intervention médicale et qu' il ya une
hémorragie on met pas un pansement
on sort les gros moyens et on sauve la
personne cj les jeunes ont prévenu ils
sont prêts à passer les fêtes ici en
famille à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle des marais de coignières et
les annonces des manuels sommes accros
ont fait réagir également la classe
politique yvelinoise en première ligne
ces élus qui ont rencontré le président
de la république à l'elysée ce vendredi
karl olive maire ait l'air de poissy
appelle notamment à la fin du mouvement
des gilets jaunes à plaisir joséphine
coleman berger salue la décision des
manuels macron de vouloir travailler
avec les maires c'était l'une des
revendications avancées par ces élus
vendredi la sénatrice les républicains
des yvelines sophie primas elle se
satisfait du retour de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires une mesure
une mesure mise en oeuvre sous à nicolas
sarkozy lorsqu'il était président enfin
à gauche benoît hamon trouve ces mesures
annoncées insuffisantes et notamment sur
la jeunesse on vous parlait tout à
l'heure des lycées une colère qui
s'exprime également chez les professeurs
du lycée dumont-d'urville à maurepas
hier près de 80 % d'entre eux étaient en
grève ils dénoncent le manque de moyens
et la dégradation progressive du climat
scolaire est le 28 novembre dernier le
proviseur de l'établissement était
agressé par un élève ses enseignants
demandent la création d'un poste de cpe
et de deux postes d'assistants
d'éducation
c'est une première en france les
salariés du plateau de satory vont
pouvoir se déplacer on avait des
autonomes date est doté pardon de
perception est tendue et développé par
bd comme elle était inaugurée lundi
marylène yapi chi lan elle s'appelle
framboise et litchi et s'avance tout
seul l'institut vd com a développé ses
navettes autonome pour étoffer l'offre
de transport et permettre aux
travailleurs du plateau de satory
d'effectuer le kilomètre manquant entre
le dernier arrêt de bus et le plateau on
va vraiment allé très très rapidement
sur un usage quotidien de cette mobilité
comme un service de transport
aujourd'hui tout à fait comparables
quand vous prenez de bus qu'on vous
prenez le métro
ce sera la même qualité de service la
même régularité qui sera offerte pour
ses débuts sa vitesse est limitée à 15
km heure elle est reliée à 16 satellite
via une antenne gps et comprend huit
capteurs appelés lidar pour détecter le
moindre danger de leader sur le toit qui
permettent de détecter les bâtiments on
va avoir un lidar 3d ici un de chaque
côté bien entendu voilà qui permettent
de docteur de voir ce qui se passe sur
les côtés et enfin on va voir des l'ida
en bas
4 donc et qui vont permettre notamment
de déclencher la chaîne de sécurité
c'est à dire que s'il ya une personne
qui arrive elle avait tu sa rive les
navettes autonome ne sont pas totalement
livrée à elle-même elle communique avec
les opérateurs du local de supervision
du mobile âme
ce service gratuit est une première en
france si c'est dans le département que
l'innovation ce fait les entreprises les
recherches les laboratoires vienne
s'implante et créer les emplois de
demain est créé et l'aménagement du
territoire de demain et les facilités de
déplacement de demain encore en phase
d'expérimentation ce sont les salariés
de bd comme qui en bénéficieront dans un
premier temps l'objectif final étant une
couverture plus large du territoire
nous vous en parlions hier dans ce
journal la 32e édition du téléthon s'est
achevée ce week-end deux jours marathon
pour la recherche contre les myopathies
et qui ont été bien suivi notamment à
magny les hameaux et montigny le
bretonneux où nous étions alors quel
premier bilan dressé sur le secteur est
divine bonsoir daniel basons mon chien
est le coordinateur sur le secteur
irving est pour le téléthon alors au
niveau national et les promesses de dons
ont reculé cette année alors on sait
vous n'est pas forcément de chiffres à
nous donner encore sur le téléthon dans
les yvelines
est ce qu'il a été bon ce téléthon de
leurs neuf pour les premières modalités
une très bonne ambiance très bonne
participation sur le département en
c'est vrai que le compteur 1 national a
un petit peu baissé on va dire mais bon
arrive maintenant
ne 36-35 internet épi l'ensemble des des
manifestations ou lynché du géant
commencé cet après midi à faire les
rendements tête
on va en parler juste après vous n'aviez
pas peur avec le climat actuel à la
mobilisation notamment des gilets jaunes
que les yvelinois ce déplacement sur
c'est sûr c'est téléthon j'étais assez
serein sur sa non sur notre département
en a eu aucune manifestation de
supprimer tout ça il ya eu peut-être un
des endroits un peut-être une belle
soirée de participation m'en sers
perçoit quand même que les les dons
viennent quand même donc qui malgré la
non participation sur les manifestations
les français sénateurs ont donné ce
chiffre notamment hier dans le journal
19 1500 euros environ récolté à magny
les hameaux on voit que la cause du
téléthon au niveau local en tout cas
mobilise toujours chacun mobilise
toujours et puis toutes ces grosses
manifestations
on va dire sur maintiennent en
maintenant si on veut augmenter la
collecte
on a juste une chose à faire c'est
augmenter le nombre de manifestants et
on peut toujours donner vous le disais
tout à l'heure d'internet et des données
qui s'affiche alors on le disait vous
êtes le coordinateur yvelines est qu'est
ce qu'on doit retenir de ce week-end de
mobilisation comme d'habitude de
nombreuses animations dans beaucoup de
villes leur yvelines de nombreuses
animations mais moi je retiens surtout
c'est que cette année suite à une
suppression du du standard téléphonique
de vélizy nos amis les audiences ont été
rénovés des très grands partenaires nous
aider tout au long d affaires des
nouveaux contrats et puis à aider les
manifestations au niveau local tout ça
dans les rayons ce club en ce sens voilà
je tiens absolument à les remercier des
lances comme rain man sur ma
coordination renmans je travaille
énormément avec eux et heureusement
c'est une entente et cette coordination
yvelines sc donc tous les civils le sait
le gdri également jeu par deux
de saint-arnoult jusqu à maisons
laffitte en hauteur à peu près de saint
germain il ya ben un petit peu que
détaché mais bon nous amis ben on
voulait rester dans les yvelines est ce
donc voilà mais non il ya eu très bonne
village à bout d'ivan mais s'est très
bien passé l'ensemble un ans et je suis
très satisfait mais mené quelques
remontées quand on a aujourd'hui centre
est bonne on l'accomplît une grosse
mobilisation on a vu qu'on était c'est
ce week-end on voit les images à
montigny-le-bretonneux à magny les
hameaux également on l'a compris une
grosse mobilisation vous en parliez tout
à l'heure daniel bazin le programme
maintenant pour vous ça va être de deux
comptes et tous ces dons de
décentraliser le devoir de centraliser
tous un puits de faire augmenter toute
cette belle collègue quand bédié au
niveau de la fm
il est donc sas a déjà démarré c'est un
on a dû juin démarre aujourd'hui on a
pris de l'avancé un petit peu parce que
ce qu'on soit si des organisateurs ben
écoute le message c'est de faire
remonter le plus rapidement possible à
mon et fêtes de noël qu'on puisse
remonter la plupart m'ont aidé dans
alors après il y aura toujours des
compléments qui viendront s'associer à
saint anne à tour des des retardataires
en me dire ça travail qui a selon ses
termes excellent week-end c'est prenant
donc tous les après midi jusqu'à 1 c'est
tard le soir
non qu surpris et on ne manquera pas de
vous faire remonter ses résultats sur le
secteur robin s du téléthon merci daniel
loiseau
d'abord il discute beaucoup je rappelle
que vous êtes le coordinateur sur le
secteur yvelines est du téléthon vous
pouvez encore donner au téléthon le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas d'écran
pour eux pour faire ce don alors que la
coop 24 se tient en ce moment en pologne
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines organise l arc si
quick et jusqu'au 14 décembre
interventions scientifiques tables
rondes expositions rencontres ponctuent
cet événement dédié à l'arctique
principales zones du monde témoins mais
aussi victimes du réchauffement
climatique
ce mardi grande journée au programme à
la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt vous voyez à l'image est des
experts venus de sibérie et du groenland
présent auprès des étudiants de l'ueh ce
qu est de paris saclay les objectifs de
cet événement collectées au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude de faire un
état des lieux et de créer des synergies
entre toutes ses forces en relation avec
différents types de savoirs pour essayer
d'avancer dans des projets innovants
incluant les étudiants les autochtones
sur ces questions de changement
climatique et de tous les changements
environnementaux que cela entraîne et de
tous ces changements socioculturels et
c'est donc il ya à la fois l'idée de
communication de forcer une
communication de faire naître des
nouveaux projets et aussi de communiquer
à un large public de tirer une seule
d'art larmes et de dire voilà nous
sommes des forces différentes nous avons
des savoirs différentes on peut
s'associer pour essayer d'aller de
l'avant et de mieux étudier ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
et elle m'a rejoint en plateau mélanie
poquet bonsoir en ces temps hivernaux
pas toujours facile de profiter de
l'extérieur c'est aussi l'occasion de se
rendre dans les salles culturelles de
l'agglomération alors chaque week-end de
nombreux rendez-vous sont ne soit pas
manquer à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mélanie poquet pour votre coup de coeur
de la semaine vous avez sélectionné deux
sorties alors si vous voulez être
époustouflé des portés acrobatiques et
des envolées pyramidale direction le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
scène nationale accueille la compagnie
xy alors il n'est pas encore minuit
c'est le nom de cette création imaginée
22 acrobates qui se porte qui voltigent
des duos des quatuors qu'ils se font se
défont sans cesse il n'est pas encore
minuit s'interroge notamment sur le
rapport du groupe au vivre ensemble
[Musique]
et la compagnie fait trois
représentations sur la scène nationale
le spectacle est à voir en famille dès
l'âge de 8 ans au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on va à s'émerveiller mélanie à
elancourt le public va rigoler oui il
est jeune il est belge et chaque soir il
fait rire ses auditeurs avec sa
compatriote charline van acker et son
journal sur france inter alors alex
vizorek sera sur la scène du prix smile
en cours ce samedi pas de brèves ce soir
là mais un décryptage de l'art alex
vizorek est une oeuvre d'art où vont se
côtoyer bergson rostropovitch et pamela
anderson
le public va pouvoir découvrir une autre
facette de l'humoriste
c'est comme la politique c'est pas parce
qu'on n'y comprend rien qu'on ne peut
pas en fait ça nadine morano l'a bien
compris
lequel des deux est un tableau fauviste
ya un piège sachez que malick n'était
pas hyper content de son travail
non mais et pourtant il n'avait pas
dépassé les spectacles ce soir on va
parfois apprendre des choses
et puis de temps en temps une petite
blague de cuves pour récupérer tout vous
voyez alors ce sont des sur deux idées
de spectacles parmi tant d'autres bien
d'autres rendez vous se passe aussi ce
week-end pour être sûr de ne rien rater
grégory rendez vous sur le site du
casque ou dans l'émission le 7-8 culture
votre émission et mélanie a retrouvé
dans un instant sur tv 78 juste avant
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que noël
approche à grands pas sous le sapin
l'univers harry potter avec ses nombreux
produits dérivés devraient être encore
bien représenté dans les yvelines les
magasins pour face à une grosse demande
de la part des fans avec une
effervescence depuis la sortie du
deuxième volet des animaux fantastiques
michael et demi d'euros après 45 minutes
de transport armen arrive enfin dans son
lieu préféré son poudlard à lui une
boutique versailles est spécialisée dans
les produits dérivés harry potter après
avoir regardé les huit films en trois
jours ce passionné a craqué s'est décidé
à faire chauffer une nouvelle fois la
carte blanche en fait je pense que
l'univers et nous a tellement inspiré on
on se sent s'y sent tellement bien en
fait quand on quand on se plonge dedans
qu'on a envie d'avoir
voilà des petits trucs qui qui nous
permettent d'y rester en fait c'est en
s'entourant petit à petit de tous ces
trucs là on se dit en fait moi aussi je
veux en faire partie
pour répondre à la demande toujours plus
croissante la boutique ouverte en 2017
propose aujourd'hui près de 2500
références dont de nombreux objets
dérivés des animaux fantastiques la
nouvelle saga issus de l'univers harry
potter et qui redynamise la franchise
depuis deux ans avec le phénomène des
animaux fantastiques
il ya un
nouvelle une nouvelle vague de fans
harry potter on à la nouvelle génération
en fait qui connaît pas forcément harry
potter et qui a peut-être lui un harry
potter et qui a regardé les animaux
fantastiques
il ya une nouvelle vague en fait qu'un
train arrivait la magie d'harry potter
et des animaux fantastiques a également
touché ce magasin culturel des
clayes-sous-bois peluche baguette dvd
surtout une quarantaine de livres sont
mises en avant dans les allées
actuellement on peut retrouver les
animaux fantastiques sous forme d'un
livre
pour les passionnés les règles du kitsch
pour les plus jeunes un pop up de
poudlard
ainsi poudlard n'aura plus de secrets
pour nos petits lecteurs
chaque semaine plus d'une centaine de
livres sur le célèbre sorcier sont
vendus ici dans cette enseigne
des chiffres qui devraient augmenter l
approche de noël je suis venu pour les
tomes 4 5 chiche set en poche pour matt
était qu'il veut ça pour noël la vienne
tombé dedans dans la lecture chez les
grenats et donc elles adorent ça et
comme en plus à l'année plus de vingt
ans après la sortie du premier livre
harry potter ne semble pas avoir pris
une ride auprès des fans et reste l'une
des franchises les plus puissantes au
monde
l'univers aurait engrangé à ce jour près
de 26 milliards de dollars de recettes
depuis son lancement la fin du set 8
journal cette édition est bien sûr à
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec télé 78
[Musique]